[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
e
un transa de vuelo
sí no
luego un verso comienzo cosa
se verá por rasguear y me pongo a cantar
y campea forma de salir
y
se me da por rasguear y me pongo a
cantar y campeón forma de shandong
compañero
que cuando te subas
la ruta sonora de mi almacenar
como yo rodará por esos rumbos que hay
en mí
[Música]
aunque más como yo rodará por esos
rumbos que hay en mí
[Música]
a buscar
el vestido de rojo mi carta
he colgado la estrella de mi canto
en el verano
entonces
araña en un pedazo de la noche
yo estoy en la cruz de la vigilia
mordiendo me pega
hombre
para ir a buscarte
[Música]
- a manos de mi esperanza y al otro
duelo
uno solo
salvaje el cual relámpago de tu sangre
que me llamó
el reloj
[Música]
yo estoy en la cruz del ady gil
comiéndome un pedazo de tus sombras para
ir a buscarte
solté las alarmas de mi esperanza y el
futuro de mi corazón
por qué
el relámpago de tu sangre que me llevo
o el reloj
es un amor
[Aplausos]
salgo a caminar
por la cintura cósmica del sur
piso en la región maxwell metal del
viento y de la luz
siento al caminar toda la piel de
américa en mí
y ando en mi sangre un río que libera
[Música]
con
sol de alto perú
rostro bolivia esta soledad
[Música]
un verde brasil
persa bichi le cubre y mineral
sólo desde el sur así era entraña marca
total por a raíz de un grito destinado a
crecer
y yo estoy yo
todas las cosas
todas las manos comas
[Música]
de canción en el viento en cantar
conmigo cantar hermano me dijo
[Música]
pero tu esperar
con hombres
no
[Música]
si un paraguas
de luz colombia básica fetal
cuba de alto sol nombra en el viento a
mexico ancestral
continente azul que en nicaragua busca
su raíz para que luche el hombre de país
en país
[Música]
por él
todas las derrotas todas las manos
toda la zona
[Música]
de canciones del viento canta conmigo
canta hermano américas
libera tu esperanza
[Música]
por un hombre con amor
no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
los hierros de su rey
veamos
no escucharán tristeza
y a mí
en mi corazón
yéndome así
[Música]
sí
y la zona
yo te quiero
[Música]
y a mí
y volteamos la flor
[Música]
sí
y si mamá no seas manicura
[Música]
sí
como puedes vivir
todo solo
[Música]
y
t
soy
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo
[Música]
hoy
sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
él
por más
bien
[Música]
sí
esto
foliares party
[Música]
no
en ella
porque sí
[Música]
pero
[Risas]
[Música]
así
de mi hijo
[Música]
el rey
entonces
[Música]
por mí
y
sí
miami
[Música]
esto
[Aplausos]
[Música]